madame la présidente madame la Première
ministre mesdames et messieurs les
ministres Mesdames et Messieurs les
présidents de commission mes chers
collègues
les démocraties gagnent les guerres et
dans cette hémicycle la résonné il y a
plus d'un siècle de nombreux débats les
commissions de la chambre ont questionné
parfois rue de loyer le gouvernement y
compris sur la conduite des opérations
militaires alors il est toujours
nécessaire de débattre et
particulièrement dans ces circonstances
voilà pourquoi nous vous remercions
Madame la Présidente d'avoir engagé une
coopération entre notre assemblée et
l'assemblée ukrainienne voilà pourquoi
nous vous remercions Madame la première
ministre d'avoir répondu par ce débat
notre interpellation du 12 juillet
dernier
la guerre qui gronde à l'est de l'Europe
n'est pas un simple conflit territorial
cette guerre est celle d'un régime
politique autoritaire et brutal qui
depuis des années déjà a servi son
peuple pour mieux organiser la
servicement de ses voisins proches et
moins proches cette guerre est celle
d'un autocrate Vladimir Poutine
rappelons-nous déjà l'occupation de la
Crimée l'infiltration au dos basse près
de 16000 morts Ukrainiens déjà
la guerre qui compte à l'est est une
guerre contre les libertés
contre le droit contre la démocratie
contre l'universalisme de ses valeurs
une guerre en Europe et contre l'Europe
capable parfois dans l'unité de montrer
le meilleur d'elle-même elle sourde
depuis longtemps déjà de cyberguer en
ingérence électorale d'élimination
ciblées en guerre idéologique via des
chaînes de désinformation il faut être
avec les dictateurs sans naïveté et son
complaisance et les tenir pour ce qu'ils
sont des ennemis de la démocratie
depuis le 24 février l'Ukraine est en
arme pour faire face avec un courage qui
force l'admiration
aux forces militaires et paramilitaires
russes bras armés d'une idéologie qui
nie son existence bras armée d'un
pouvoir qui ne connaît que la force et
le cynisme en défendant sa vie le peuple
ukrainien défend le droit et en l'aidant
nous donnons de la force aux droits et
nous nous défendons nous-mêmes alors que
pointe la stratégie de la mer brûlée
après la stratégie bien connue de la
terre brûlée le droit exige le
rapatriement des centaines de milliers
d'Ukrainiens déportés en Russie dont
plusieurs milliers d'enfants exposés à
des adoptions forcées
le droit oblige à regarder en face les
charniers les salles de torture les
exécutions sommaire et les viols que
subissent les populations des zones
occupées et mettre les mots sur ces
faits enivrant à l'éprouvante
documentation des crimes de guerre et
des crimes de l'humanité le droit
commande que c'est bourreaux soient
traduits devant les tribunaux
le droit ne connaît j'ai insiste mes
chers collègues que les frontières
internationalement reconnues de
l'Ukraine celle de 1991 et aucun et en
aucun cas les référendums potamines qui
viennent de se dérouler la moindre
ambiguïté sur ce point laisserait planer
l'ombre de l'abandon de millions de
personnes dans ces zones de non-droit
aux mains de leur bureau le don-basse
c'est l'Ukraine la Crimée c'est
l'Ukraine
le droit c'est l'interdiction de
collaborer de quelques manières que ce
soit avec le régime criminel russe et de
soutenir même indirectement son effort
de guerre c'est la raison pour laquelle
est députés socialiste déposeront un
amendement pour que soit saisi et verser
à l'Ukraine les dividendes et autres
gains que les entreprises auraient
obtenu en demeurant en Russie
c'est la raison pour laquelle Eutelsat
doit cesser de diffuser les chaînes
russes en dehors de l'Europe c'est la
raison pour laquelle totale énergie qui
a continué d'exploiter des hydrocarbures
au risque de fournir même indirectement
des moyens à l'aviation russe qui
bombarde à Mario Paul doit quitter la
Russie et ne serait sans état d'âme
recevoir les 440 millions d'euros de
dividendes pour le premier semestre 2022
de sa participation dans Novatech
le droit c'est légitime défense du
peuple ukrainien des démocraties ont le
devoir de s'engager à leur côté en
livrant des armes la France l'a fait
elle doit plus encore continuer de le
faire nous appelons madame la Première
ministre tous les députés républicains à
rester unis pour convaincre nos
compatriotes de la nécessité des efforts
accomplis et des efforts à venir le
débat aujourd'hui était nécessaire il
convient de le prolonger et d'offrir un
autre assemblée nationale la possibilité
de s'unir dans une résolution de soutien
à l'Ukraine net et la plus large
possible c'est le sens de la résolution
que les socialistes déposent aujourd'hui
je vous le dis à chaque fois qu'il en
ira de la liberté et du droit le
gouvernement nous trouvera à ses côtés
oui les démocraties doivent gagner cette
guerre par le rétablissement du droit et
de la souveraineté ukrainienne ce n'est
qu'à cette condition qu'il y aura un
jour nouveau pour le peuple ukrainien
pour les peuples d'Europe et pour le
peuple russe je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]